alternate so that tip one easily by  Adams and here's Westbrook the reigning  MVP threw down 29 points in 37 minutes  with and gives it away in a running  layup  you get Stephen Adams in foul trouble  that drink Lee enhances your chance all  what a drive died of it I think is just  fine jazz will take that all night when  the call sticks and Carmela wants the  foot fake Oh Jonas runs it inside and a  two hander and the assist goes the  Donovan Donovan on that stuff and go  drive he's got a lane Oh hammers it down  a big finish 15 for Donovan what a  matchup Westbrook versus Mitchell  the rookie against the ten-year-old a  reigning MVP Donovan floater up top got  it  Oh Donovan what a shot Donovan spins on  Patterson beautiful move Oh put it down  another spinner a beautiful shot by  Donovan Vicki looks inside Skip pass  Donovan slides in over the top of Adams  for two more Ricky - Donovan 17 on the  shot clock heritage spinner floater and  put it down Wow